- [somber music plays]
- [indistinct chatter]
- [copier whirring]
- [crying in distance]
- [keyboard banging]
- [upbeat music plays]
♪ I found love ♪
♪ Didn't even know I needed it ♪
♪ But I found love ♪
♪ Never even crossed my mind ♪
♪ I found love ♪
♪ Had a garden,
never weeded it ♪
♪ But I found love ♪
♪ Took an apple just in time ♪
♪ I found love in the fall ♪♪
- Dogs are disgusting creatures.
They smell,
their mouths are too wet,
and they constantly demand
your attention
like dumb, slutty babies.
People think they're cute when
really they're just overbred
mutants too stupid
to beg for death.
They turn people
into complete idiots.
- [in slow-motion]
There's a dog?
- ♪ I found love
in this world ♪
♪ And my heartstrings
just unfurled ♪
♪ I found love in the spring ♪
- [in slow-motion]
I'm your mommy.
- ♪